If you look at the structure of
distributed systems today, what you'll see is there
are applications in the applications that users use.
And there are system services and there is
a micro kernel that's sitting at the
bottom. And the system services include things like
file server, web server, Window manager, database manager,
and the network stack for applications to do
network communication with servers that may be
on remote machines. And the micro kernel itself
may be responsible for process management and managing
the hardware resources and providing inter-process communication, both
intra-machine among these services. As well as
inter-machine through the network stack, the remote machines
on the local area network. We've seen that this is a structure we like to see
in the operating system. And in fact, from many of the previous
lessons that we have looked at in operating system design and implementation,
both for a single processor, for a multi-processor, and a networked operating
system, this kind of structure lends
itself to extensibility and yet high performance.